[Music]
I'm getting slow in my oh there Jeffers
even you've got to hope to die young not
for lack of trying
at the end of Man of Steel Zod was
fighting Superman there's lasers ripping
apart buildings when things are blowing
up
Bruce Wayne blames Superman he has the
power to wipe out the entire human race
if we believe there's even a 1% chance
it is our enemy we have to destroy an
Sigma have seeds Batman as a criminal
brutal and unforgiving this bat
vigilante it's like a one-man reign of
terror nobody cares about Clark Kent
taking on the Batman as if matters do
everything by the books Batman is do
whatever it takes
what's your position on the back of a
giant gun Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I
love it I love bringing people together
how are we Lex hi hello Lex it is a
pledge oh wow that is a good grip you
should not pick a fight with this person
like skills competitive with Bruce Wayne
he's learned everything about him
Lex hates Superman learned everything
about him like it's kind of the puppet
master kind of controlling these two
heroes forcing them into conflict the
greatest gladiator match in the history
of the world
Son of Krypton versus bat of Gotham
you're psychotic there's a three
syllable word for any thought too big
for little minds
at the core of every human heart there
is this conflict between the better
angels of our nature and our dark side
you
ZT didn't click select us and sophistica
passage to the coast a gladiator on come
today